那普及一下NPD人格这个事儿好不好？
有想听的扣个1，
我普及了之后，
你可能就会恍然大悟，
你说原来啊，
我一直是在被NPD控制，
被NPD吸血，
被NPD摧残。
NPD全称叫做自恋型人格障碍，
它是一种心理疾病，
这种心理疾病是在所有的心理咨询师都放弃的一款心理疾病，
换句话说是心理学产生的。
这些年当中没有任何一例成功的案例可以把自恋型人格障碍给治愈。
明白了吧？
啊，
这就是跟大家讲这个NPD到底有多可怕，
接下来我给大家讲一下NPD它的一些特征，
它的特征就是第一，
他永远是主宰，
他永远是中心，
他永远是对的，
任何出现矛盾了都是你的错，
就哪怕他自己被辞职了，
他自己工作不认真，
他自己出现了事业上的滑铁卢了，
都是你的错，
你不带财呀，
对吧？
你天天耍耍脸色呀对吧？
你不给我帮衬啊，
你不借钱给我啊，
都是你的错。
第二，
你能给我做饭，
你能给我洗衣服，
你能给我处对象，
那都是你祖坟上冒青烟了，
哪怕你挣钱比我多，
哪怕你资源比我丰富，
哪怕你家庭比我好，
我能看上你就是你，
我能看上你就是一种恩赐，
明白吗？
就在NPD的世界里面，
哪怕你比他有钱，
你比他有钱，
你比他有资源，
哪怕你各方面条件都比他好。
但是在NPD的眼里的话，
他能看上你，
都是他对你的施舍，
他能让你给他做饭，
就让你伺候他都是你该感恩，
你该跪谢皇恩，
明白了吗？
第三，
NPD会篡改自己的记忆，
他说谎张嘴就来，
他跟你以前发生的哪些事情的话，
所有的错都会归结到你的身上，
说谎张嘴就来，
他篡改了自己的记忆，
他觉得自己永远是对的，
一定是他提了一个正确的建忆，
你没有遵从，
所以才导致了今天这个结果。
第4 NPD人格从来不会承认别人的优秀，
从来都觉得，
哎呦老板能挣这么多钱的话，
就是老板运气好，
哎哟，
我那个主管之所以能当主管的话，
就是因为他们家有裙带关系，
哎呦这个女同事之所以能成为销冠的话，
肯定是他跟老板，
这你知道吧，
所有的人比他优秀的话，
一定不是他自己有什么原因，
一定不是他自己懒惰，
一定不是他自己没有付出这个劳洞，
一定是别人通过什么不可告人的手段才比他优秀，
这个世界上就没有别人比他优秀。
我看到舅舅买新房子了的话，
他舅舅算什么东西，
又看到表哥买新车的话，
表哥算什么东西，
明白了吗？
他嫉妒心贼强。
第5，
他在人前表现的非常大方，
这是属于那种觉得自己又优秀又大方那种的，
就是在人前一个样，
在家里另外一个样，
就是在人前恨不得他就是江湖老大，
假装自己就是江湖老大，
大家一起去KTV的话，
他恨不得就是举飞起来的话，
大家都得敬他一句。
哥，
然后在家里的话，
你在家里又是另外一副嘴脸，
NPD人格，
窝里恨，
嫉妒心强，
撒谎张嘴就来，
而且你对他好，
你有一件事儿没有顺他的心意的话，
他就咬死你，
你们所有的兄弟姐妹啊，
无论你是男生还是女生，
如果你的父母是NPD人格，
那么你一定要努力学习，
一定要好好攒钱，
一定要认真工作，
一定要飞得越远越好，
一定要从你的内心生出一股力量，
就是你只有逃离NPD，
你才有可能获得幸福，
获得真正的自由。
如果你愚孝，
如果你被这些道德枷锁，
情感所绑架，
如果你被人心理操控，
那你这一辈子就是被别人吸血的这样一个玩偶，
被别人吸血的这样一个工具人。
听明白了啊，
如果你的伴侣是NPD人格，
那你也只有一条路，
你只有逃离这个NPD的人格，
你才有可能给你的孩子创造一个自由的空间，
你才有可能让你的孩子不被NPD人格搞成抑郁症，
你们一定要往心里去，
记得点赞关注哦。